[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy whose game
puns are on a different level and this
video we're breaking down the brand new
movie free guy the film is filled with
hidden cameos easter eggs and cool
little details that make it one of the
best movies this year throughout this
video we'll be going over the story and
also its ending to give our thoughts on
the movie overall full spoilers ahead so
if you haven't seen it then go and
console yourself with another video
smash the thumbs up button and ninten
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
like this every day without the way i
hope you're ready player one now let's
get into free guy okay so free guy
follows an npc known as guy played by
ryan reynolds guy slowly discovers that
he's actually a video game character
trapped inside a grand theft auto esque
simulation whilst this seems like a very
surface level action comedy we soon
discover that the film is actually a
love story between the two developers
behind the systems that augment the game
in the movie we meet millie and keys
played by jody coma and joe kiri
respectively kiri actually admitted this
week that he doesn't wash his hair as it
cleans itself and i'm just can can
celebrities stop sharing this [ __ ]
please this is why i don't interview you
[ __ ] now moving on these are
two characters that created the world's
first artificial intelligence and
initially the pair developed a game
called life itself that would allow
humanity to observe that life
finds a way the system is completely
unique and it allows the life forms
inside of it to build their own fully
sustained system so that we can see how
much better stuff is without what
happened in 2020 however wheelin a
greedy game developer named antoine
played by taika with td had other plans
and that he stole his algorithm he then
applied it to free city as the basis for
the npcs and this allowed players to
come in and basically do whatever they
wanted we discover that millie has a
lawsuit against antoine and she breaks
into free city in order to find evidence
that he stole the algorithm and this is
where she comes across guy now in the
movie we learned that keys actually
planted a program within guy that would
spark up life inside the simulation and
that this would be set off when he came
across the love of his life guy was
someone who was constantly searching for
his soulmate and coming across this
would mean that it would spark up
something between the two which would
have a knock on effect inside the sim as
we learn at the end of the movie keys
actually love millie and he based this
soulmate idea on her guy passing millie
in the street sets off a chain of events
in which he breaks from his programming
and begins to learn he offers to help
milly get what she's after but she says
he's not a high enough level and as we
know women they only care when you get
to level 69 now whereas free city is
pretty much afraid for all guy decides
to do good and slowly he goes viral on
the internet as a hero no one realizes
that he's actually an npc and everyone
including millie starts to fall in love
with him all the girls say he's pretty
fly for a white guy and he catches the
attention of not only millie but also
pokemane in one of the film's many
cameos now there's a ton of youtubers in
the film including ninja and also laser
beam dantdm and jacksepticeye there's
also ign bloody ign probably give it a 5
out of 10 for being too free of a city
probably started off the review by
saying free guy makes you feel like free
guy they're idiots anyway the cameos
extend beyond this and since its release
we've also learned that several actors
have given their voices to characters in
the film this includes hugh jackman who
appears at the start there's also the
rock tina fey john krasinski and
channing tatum appears as one of the
avatars in probably the funniest scene
in the movie on top of this chris evans
shows up at the end when guy gets some
avengers power-ups including captain
america's shield and also hulk's fist
this was possible because disney
recently acquired fox and thus they were
able to move the right across for this
movie there's also a lightsaber and a
poster for deadpool pops about one point
which is of course a character close to
reynolds heart we can also catch the
gravity and portalgun at one point and
the film is filled to the brim with nods
to movies and games alex trebek also
appears and sadly the jeopardy host
passed away in 2020 before this film was
released now i have to say the movie is
really a blast and as someone who didn't
think it would work i was pleasantly
surprised the film deals with a lot of
themes including individuality finding a
purpose love friendship and also
appreciating the good in life guy
initially has an existential crisis upon
learning that he's a game character and
he fears that he's not real he worries
that nothing matters but if you spend
your days just making youtube videos
does anything matter really probably not
but you know we find the good in life
and that's what guy very much does with
his own existence now antoine is in the
middle of launching free city 2 which
will completely replace everything in
the first game and mean that guy's
programming is wiped though it seems
like million keys original code is
completely missing they realized that
antoine was too lazy to scrub the
reflections and thus guy catches it when
opening his blinds a routine that he
goes through every day it's a race
against time as they try to get to the
island beyond the sea in order to expose
antoine he throws everything he can at
them including a half developed
bodybuilding clone of guy with a blue
shirt tattoo who he learns called the
dude guy manages to beat him and he gets
to the island which exposes the paradise
that million keys developed antoine
destroys most of the servers but millie
arrives and says she'll drop the lawsuit
if he agrees to leave her code intact he
does but he's still arrested and is a
bit of a dick also shout outs how many
roles taiko utiti is getting at the
moment you bloody deserve it now life
itself becomes a hit and milly visits
guy who makes her realize that keys
actually loves her this is the true
story of free guy and the pair end up
hugging in the street whilst guy and his
friend buddy are reunited realizing that
they're now living in paradise it's an
awesome very positive way to end the
movie and though a sequel hasn't been
announced yet i'd absolutely love to see
the characters return now as for my
thoughts on the film i'm sure you can
tell that i really enjoyed it and it
massively exceeded my expectations ryan
reynolds always goes above and beyond in
the films that he's in and just in the
same way that he managed to elevate
deadpool the actor took what could have
been a pretty mediocre movie and made it
to the next level i absolutely loved all
the easter eggs and cameos too and it
felt like the best adaptation of a grand
theft auto game that we could really
hope for it really was a love letter to
the way that gaming is right now and i
think that it's great they got so many
real world figures involved as it added
a level of authenticity that showed the
creative team knew what they were doing
i actually got asked if i wanted to be
in free guy but i said i don't work for
free guy hey no actually yeah they they
rejected me and didn't call me at all
some review bombing the movie because
that's what morons with no life do isn't
it anyway it could it could have easily
just felt like they were just hopping on
the craze in order to make money like
some other video game movies do but we
get a very deep layered film with a lot
to unpack from it i'm gonna wait until
the movie is out digitally then do a big
deep dive on it but i can't wait to
watch it again free guy was great and in
the end i'm scoring it an 8 out of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on free guy so make sure you
comment below and let me know we're
running a competition right now and
giving away three mcu box sets on the
30th of august and all you have to do to
be with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so that's
you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want to see some
more marvel related stuff then make sure
you check out our breakdown of captain
america the first avenger it's an oldie
but a goodie and we found a lot of never
before seen easter eggs and hidden plot
details that only now pay off with the
first episode of what if if not then
thank you for sitting until the end of
the video i've been paul you've been the
best and i'll see you next time take
care peace